let's first talk about the credit card
uh i've probably told everyone on this
show a million times about the credit
card maybe hearing it from you would be
better in terms of how it works yeah
sure thing so i mean
if you've been living under a rock and
haven't heard we're you know we're the
first company in the world to launch a
bitcoin rewards credit card this is it
right here i'll see if i can get a
little clink sound
you know it's a nice metal card
um it's the world's first card that lets
you earn bitcoin instead of regular
cashback or airline miles so uh you get
three and a half percent cash back on in
bitcoin for your first 90 days of having
the card
one and a half percent cash back uh on
every purchase after that and there's a
bunch of other benefits across the
platform you get
rebates on your trading volumes you get
higher refer friend bonuses um
and actually right now through the end
of the year we're running a promotion
where if you sign up for the card and
make your first transaction before the
end of january we'll give you 75 bucks
on our platform that you can use to uh
buy bitcoin so the card's been live
since the summer i've got some
interesting stats to share with you but
um that's the card at a high level uh
it's still really the the only premium
card in the market right now
that lets you uh you know spin credit
and earn bitcoin so i went back uh and i
looked at the rewards that i've been
earning and uh you're gonna correct me
if i'm wrong here but i think you earn
what is it uh three or four percent for
the first like 90 days and then one and
a half percent after that
that's right three and a half percent
for the first 90 days one and a half
percent on every transaction after that
okay so those numbers they seem like
kind of what i would consider normal
credit card type returns maybe on the
higher end of a normal range we get paid
in bitcoin and obviously bitcoin's price
has gone up especially since over the
summer when you guys launched it and so
one point i went and i looked and i had
earned eight percent back on my
purchases and i was sitting there
thinking to myself like damn every time
i swipe this card if i just keep
thinking it's gonna be some big
percentage whatever the percentage ends
up being five percent or you know 25
percent uh i'm going to spend more money
like this is a problem
and what i realized was there's really
no other way to get outsized uh kind of
rebates or rewards other than you get
paid in an asset that then appreciates
in price right like this has to be uh on
the actual like almost like real return
basis the highest reward credit card uh
if bitcoin continues to go up over time
right yeah i mean look it's it's
changing the game earning airline miles
or cash back you are guaranteed
that over time those rewards that you're
getting are going to be worth less
um and you know i believe and i know you
believe that if you're earning bitcoin
uh regularly and you have a long-term
you know time horizon the bitcoin is
going to be worth more so you know what
that translates into for our court
holders is exactly what you described
yes it's a three and a half or a one and
a half percent rate like the day that
you make the swipe but over time it
becomes a much higher uh effective cash
back rate as bitcoin you know
appreciates in value um so you know
people are catching on to this like
we've we've done a few surveys uh with
our card holding clients and we've
gotten some interesting data out of them
first off
in six months since we launched the card
we're already on track for folks to
spend two billion dollars on the card in
the first year
and already we've
provided over 200 bitcoin in rewards uh
to our cardholder rules which is over
you know 10 million dollars at the
current price um
furthermore
90
of the folks that have the card uh are
still holding on to every bitcoin reward
that they received so we're enabling
folks that want more bitcoin to get it
they're holding on to it um we're also
making it easy for folks to you know
come get their hands on bitcoin when
maybe uh you know they haven't been as
active in the market before and they're
looking for an easy way to start earning
bitcoin so we found that over two-thirds
of our card holders are spending less on
their traditional cash back cards and 50
of the folks that have the block fight
card uh are using it for more than 75
of their transactions now wow so all
right uh how do you guys release how
many cards are actually out in the
market yet like what's the last public
number you've released we're at about 75
000 cards at the bottom of the funnel
meaning somebody has received the card
activated it and already made a purchase
okay so we got 75 000 cards kind of in
people's hands maybe it's the way to
kind of talk about it and they're on
track to spend two billion dollars
through this card which uh for people
who don't know uh what it from like a
visa perspective that's a great launch
that's a like a market leading one is
that average how does that stack up
against other types of cards that
they've done yeah visa has been blown
away our bank partners on the card have
been blown away it's like the
they've called it the most enthusiastic
credit card launch that they've ever
seen um
and you know that's because folks
understand the value and they similar to
you once they get the card and start
using it they see the bitcoin price go
up they do the math and they get really
excited about it i mean i know
personally um i'm doing all of my
spending uh you know on this card now
and uh it's been a tremendous launch you
know an average
premium credit card monthly spend uh
mastercard or amex or around 1500 bucks
right now the average monthly spend on a
block fight card is about 3 000.
got it and then talk to us about this
number like 89 90 percent i think of
people have not sold the bitcoin that
they've earned john and i were talking
about it earlier we were just blown away
by how big of a number that is like what
do you think feeds into that it's just
bitcoin holders in general tend to hold
it it's all the training that you and
your brothers give people watching the
show
hang on to your hang on to your bitcoin
but the other thing is uh you know what
block five is probably most well known
for is our interest account product
we're one of the first places in the
world where you can hold bitcoin on our
platform and earn interest uh on your
bitcoin in bitcoin so folks are earning
these rewards from spending on the car
that bitcoin then goes into their
interest account product and compounds
even further because as your bitcoin
balance grows you earn more interest on
it uh in that account so um
you know the general behavior that we
see on our platform is folks are net
buyers of bitcoin they want to
accumulate more bitcoin and this card is
really just helping facilitate that um
and accelerate the trend that was
already in place with our clients okay
and then talk to me about the difference
between a personal credit card and a
corporate card these are only for
individuals today or can businesses also
get them
right now it's just uh for individuals
um hopefully you know by the midpoint of
next year we'll have an option where you
can get a card in the name of uh your
business awesome uh and joe john what
questions do you guys have in terms of
the credit card uh and kind of this
launch it's just absolutely insane when
you start looking at these numbers is
there a wait list for the card now or no
uh no there was a wait list uh before
launching but if you hear anyone say
oh yeah i was on the wait list you know
i don't know when my card's coming the
waitlist period is over in our app or on
our website on our website now you can
you know two three clicks actually apply
for the card get approved
and then receive it uh you know in the
mail a few days after that gotcha
can you talk about the different rewards
so can you get you can obviously get
bitcoin in return can you do cash back
can you do other cryptocurrencies and
then like what are people using it for
yeah so you can you can select to earn
your rewards in any of the
cryptocurrencies or stable coins that
are supported on our platform so if you
decide i'd rather be earning ethereum
this month or you know uniswap or
litecoin uh or actually if i just want
you know to increase my cash balance on
the block five platform where i earn
nine percent on the cash that i hold in
the form of stable coins at block five
uh you can do that as well um we see the
vast majority of people uh just stick
with the bitcoin option um but we
launched that you know flex rewards
feature uh about six weeks ago um and i
think around 15 of people have have
elected to you know get the rewards in a
different currency uh than bitcoin so
far